he was an Insider bro he was a part of
the inner workings of Andre tent and
this is the confession he actually
Muslim he's Muslim just cuz he's in
Dubai in Dubai I'm happy to be Muslim
and when I'm in Romania I'm happy to be
Christian the aabra ad you're about to
see is for adults only if you're a child
please tune off it's a medical condition
that can affect everyone and it is halal
and permissible lockdown pills for the
moment when you're not feeling up for it
available in both male and female %
authentic natural intimacy vitility
pills endorsed in TV's this morning
celebrity Dr Chris Steel issue of the
celebrity Angels magazine by aagra also
if you provide a festar review after
your purchase on Amazon you can qualify
for a fee pack terms and conditions
apply brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well inshallah
so guys there was this video going
around of some individual I don't know
who the hell he is for that matter I
don't it's a Muslim or Muslim for that
matter but he sounds like an absolute
outright simp yeah just somebody who's
probably begging for attention of the
females and has to Resort the same stuff
like you're going to see in a minute so
he's accusing Andrew Tate of being a
secret disbeliever yeah so we're going
to come to a few Quran verses and a
Hadith which tell us on what basis can
we take someone at the F of Islam uh
there's some statements that Andrew Tate
made himself uh which we're going to
come to and also an Insider who's Andrew
Tate's old friend or did business with
him who is claiming that he is a fake
Muslim let's watch for ourself in here's
the video he was an Insider bro he was a
part of the inner world workings of
Andrew tain's pimping scheme bro he
tells it how it is bro and this is the
confession Dubai I'm happy to be Muslim
and when I'm in Romania I'm happy to be
Christian my name is Eli X empa I am a
Duke propo and former head of sales and
marketing at corate Eli worked for
Andrew tapate for 2 years selling access
to his online courses at one point Eli
was working for tapate from Dubai he
actually wasn't he's Muslim just cuz
he's in Dubai cuz he wants to be friends
with all the shakes and stuff all of a
sudden he's started doing business with
shakes all of a sudden he's Muslim it's
not real can I corroborate this no how
did I find out sitting at a table in
Dubai with him is when he told us I
asked him are you actually Muslim he
said well kind of not really I'm just
kind of doing it because I'm in a I'm in
the United Arab Emirates and it's good
for public perception when was this
conversation back in December 2022
Andrew Tate converted to Islam primarily
for marketing and for connections
Marketing in terms of seeming more
righteous and reaching a new audience of
uh Islamic faith viewers the kind of
messaging around
becoming a Muslim is like a way of him
washing his reputation for instance yeah
absolutely so guys you saw that there
was a video footage of himself saying
that when he's in Dubai he's a Muslim
Etc this if I'm not mistaken the
information that's reached me Tam Khan
who's his friend said that this was from
an old video now let's go to the video
of this individual this individual who
is he to us he's a fasic he's an
evildoer both the person who is speaking
behind the video and this individual
who's his friend Eli Eli whatever his
name is yeah for that matter I'm so
sorry we don't know who the hell he is
we don't even if he's a a trustworthy
person and even if we go with that
what's the point like what's what's the
aim here so what's what is the evidence
yeah what is the evidence to show that
now not only that let's just watch this
another clip with from this individual
who is now starting to attack us yes
because we've done video support Andre
T's conversion let's watch it for a and
then we're going to come and dissect
this simp in totality in most of your
online da guys they just using Islam for
marketing purposes as well you know a
lot of them are born Muslim but they use
Islam because you know it gets a lot of
clicks and Views because Islam is
trending all of a sudden but these guys
have no critical thought they don't want
to tackle actual issues they just want
to talk about how women should be
subjugated uh How the West is bad why
they live in the west Muhammad Alid dawa
Daniel kikachu bash Europe bash America
while they liveing in these countries he
be like go go to Saudi or something bro
seriously like if I was in charge of the
government I would send Muhammad back to
Egypt so in show you can see guys he
seems he sounds like an absolute clown
he wants to send individuals back to the
country so you can see this person if he
is a Muslim he has a big nef in his out
and I doubt I don't know if he's a
Muslim I don't know who the hell is for
that matter he sounds like an outright
simp somebody who is basically a Pik me
you so you know he thinks that by
talking in this way Etc he's going to
get the girls Etc listen brother come um
if you want I can teach you Halal ways
of going about to finding a partner in
in the in the right way you don't need
to S sing woman like men who are sims
you're going to be in the friends
category for the rest of your life and
by alone with maybe a cat and some
trainers yeah so if if you're really
worried about that by thinking that
you're doing this and making accusations
towards other believers and not only
that you even questioning our heart
myself Muhammed hiju Etc that you know
we're doing it for the fames and Views
do you have the keys to the Unseen
please do tell us so we can see that
you're not a trustworthy individual for
you to accuse us and then go and accuse
Andrew tape it shows there you just
you're just a pck me simp it's as simple
as that we understand yeah um maybe life
is hard whatever for that matter now
let's come to this issue brothers and
sisters anybody come anybody that comes
to Islam with certainty we can only take
him out the fold of Islam with certainty
the prophet Muhammad peace be upon him a
companion came and said he was in the
battlefield and he was fighting and
there was an individual where he
defeated in war but he was about to
struck him and kill him and the man said
I I'll be a Muslim I'm a Muslim or I'm a
Muslim for that matter yeah okay I
accept Islam and he killed him and he
came to the prophet Muhammad him and
told him this the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam got so angry and so
upset because he said did you open he
said the man said to the prophet he only
said this to save his life and if you
think about it in a situation of War
it's the obvious is what the obvious is
yes it looks like he's doing that to
save his life but Islam does not work in
that manner when it comes to the Shar
and the capital punishments yeah the
prophet said did you open his heart and
see his reality that he's not he was
very angry so it's very very profound
and there's verses in the Quran which
pertain to this issue Allah subh says in
the Quan vers 94 very interesting and
this individual this clown absolute
backa this clown weasel um Nas yes who's
coming and even going to podcast and say
oh he's not a real Muslim Etc if there's
anyone who's a outright non-muslim
disbeliever it's you you've claimed that
you don't believe in God yes let alone
that you have let backstabbed your own
people yes you Shameless man I wish I
could see you in face one uh face to
face one day legally I'll put you in
place Allah says in the Quran in N verse
34 all you who believe when you go forth
in the fight in the cause of Allah
subhana wa ta'ala do not say to the one
who gives you a greetings of Peace Salam
you are not a Believer aspiring for the
goods of the worldly life for with Allah
are many Acquisitions you yourselves
were like that before then Allah
conferred his favor upon you so
investigate indeed Allah is ever with
what you do meaning what if somebody
gives you Salam you cannot come and say
be like oh no uh you know you're not
Allah clearly gives this UD okay for a
Believer his usle is that he's a
Believer okay he is in goodness okay his
usle is not his a f evil do is a
disbeliever so for that matter anybody
that comes to in Islam with certainty we
can only take him out of certainty so
for this s who's trying to you know SIM
for the girls Etc at the cost of
throwing his brothers let on all of us
under the bus including Andrew Tate that
oh one is a disbeliever apparently look
guys those videos are from old and
before okay it is upon every Muslim to
defend the honor of every believer when
Andrew Tate in the beginning was not a
Muslim and he was saying certain things
I came out personally and done videos
against him we do not pick and choose
okay but the Sharia called us to expose
certain falsehood that he preached not
all before he was a Muslim we did that
when he became a Muslim the Sharia
called us to welcome him be patient with
him help him and guide him whatever is
for that matter and to defend his honor
we will defend his honor whoever it is
for that matter we don't have our
loyalty is with Allah and his messenger
and and the Believers for that matter so
that's all I want to say inshallah for
the simp yes you're an absolute clown
talking about people's matters unseen
Etc that's all I wanted to say may Allah
subh keep andate firm not only is he a
Muslim you see him in every interview
calling other people to Islam so brother
and sisters we should be very careful
because the prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him said anybody that calls a
person a disbeliever either that person
is a disbeliever or he himself is a
disbeliever that's all I have to say
inah may Allah bless you guys till next
time there is a link at the bottom
brother and sisters where we are raising
funds to buy a building in Wales for a w
which is an ongoing anything that's
accumulated from that building rent uh
money that comes in is going to go for
the course for the Gaza the Palestinian
brothers and sisters to give them
Justice intellectually uh be it food be
it um helping them build their houses
back whatever it is for that matter
inshallah please there is a link for
that at the bottom inshallah please help
us to purchase that property inshallah
and I will show you guys step every step
of the way inshallah once that P that
building is purchased asalam alaykum
w